es ist eine infernale feuerkraft die
russland für seine offensive in der ost
ukraine zusammen gezogen hat
tausende geschütze raketenwerfer panzer
erbarmungslos gegen russische truppen
ganze städte in einem stahlgewitter in
schutt und asche
es ist ein brutaler vernichtungskrieg
bei dem es schon lange nicht mehr um
militärische ziele geht ein krieg der
versöhnung unmöglich macht
ich schaue auf das zerstörte mario pohl
wo meine schwester lebt die ich so oft
besucht habe ich schaue auf meine
heimatstadt kharkiv die jeden tag
bombardiert wird und ich spüre nur noch
abscheu und hass für diese russischen
truppen
igor und seine verlobte ekaterina
stammen aus der ost ukraine sie selbst
konnten gerade noch fliehen fahren jetzt
in lemberg aus aber ein großteil ihrer
familien ist im russischen bombenhagel
ausgeliefert
kommunikation ist kaum möglich seit
wochen haben sie keinen direkten kontakt
ob sie ihre familien jemals wieder sehen
wissen sie nicht wo aber vertraut darauf
dass die ukrainische armee russland
standhalten wird
unsere truppen sind vorbereitet auf
diese offensive sie waren noch nie so
bereit um den don was zu kämpfen wie
jetzt
igor und ekaterina haben putins brutale
vernichtungs strategie am eigenen leib
erfahren anfang april haben sie einen
raketenangriff auf den bahnhof in
grammatik überlebt
sie warten gerade darauf dass ihr zug
abfährt als eine rakete im bahnhof
einschlägt mehr als 50 zivilisten werden
getötet frauen und kinder
das bild einer jungen frau verfolgt aber
immer noch
[Musik]
die junge frau ertrank in tränen ich
habe runter geschaut zu ihren füßen lag
kleines mädchen bewegungslos in
blutgetränkt wahrscheinlich war es ihre
tochter
was treibt wladimir putin zu dieser
politik der vernichtung timothy snyder
ist einer der bedeutendsten historiker
der gegenwart mit laut lenz hat er das
standardwerk über die politik der
vernichtung durch stalin und hitler
geschrieben bloodlands da sind die
blutgetränkten böden von belarus polen
dem baltikum und vor allem der ukraine
der krieg gegen die ukraine und ihre
menschen putins vision von einem gros
russischen reich würde sich anschließend
an die vernichtung ideologie der großen
menschen schlechter hitler und stalin
die russische führung hat gesagt dass es
keinen ukrainischen staat und keine
ukrainische nationalen russischen
polizisten haben eine anleitung
veröffentlicht wie man die ukrainische
nation zerstören kann und sie sagen dass
jeder der sich mit der ukraine
identifiziert entweder getötet oder in
ein konzentrationslager gebracht
als nach dem abzug russischer truppen
von kiew anfang april klar wird mit
welch bestialischer brutalität die
russischen truppen auch gegen zivilisten
vorgehen
veröffentlicht die staatliche russische
nachrichtenagentur ria nowosti zur
rechtfertigung an den langen artikel den
man auch als handbuch des völkermordes
lesen kann
darin heißt es unter anderem
die nazis die ihre waffen erheben müssen
auf dem schlachtfeld vernichtet werden
und zwar so viele wie möglich dabei darf
kein unterschied gemacht werden zwischen
der armee und den freiwilligen
territorialen verteidigungskräfte und
weiter heißt es neben den höheren rängen
gibt es jede menge einfacher bürger die
sich schuldig gemacht haben nazi
mitläufer oder nazi komplizen zu sein
die ukraine als nazis zu bezeichnen ist
eine ent menschlichen de hassrede die
das töten der ukraine legitimieren soll
das ist es was vor sich geht
der feind das ist das ultimative böse
das man auslassen muss
anton ist der feind in diesem jahr aktiv
er ist 33 jahre alt pastor aus kiew mit
westlichen werten aufgewachsen eng
verbunden mit seiner heimat regelmäßig
fährt er in die ost ukraine um soldaten
an der front zu versorgen
[Musik]
wir sind uns völlig bewusst putin ein
sehr schmerzhaftes und großes narrativ
der russischen geschichte benutzt
wenn du zum beispiel mit russen sprichst
seit generationen ist diese große krieg
gegen die nazis ein extrem starkes
narrativ in ihrer geschichte
also versucht putin mit diesem narrativ
den alten schmerz mit dem aktuellen
kampf zu verbinden
hineingezwungen in einen krieg den sie
nicht wollten einer der besten freunde
antons führt eine 100 mann starke
einheit der ukrainischen armee im don
was nicht alle seiner männer sind heute
noch am leben ihre gesichter zeigen wir
aus sicherheitsgründen nicht antons
freund steht in diesen tagen an
vorderster front trotzdem hofft anton
ihm bald wieder besuchen zu können um
gemeinsam zu beten zu reden zu weinen
wenn ich dort hinkommen sind die meisten
gespräche über ihr motiv für was bringen
was ist der sinn
was ist größer sich
den soldaten und den vielen freiwilligen
kämpfern die es nicht nur ums eigene
überleben meint anton sie kämpften um
die existenz ihrer familien und ihres
landes ihrer zukunft
es wird sich alles auf dem schlachtfeld
entscheidet schon seit jahrhunderten
versucht russland unsere nation zu
setzen
jetzt kämpfen wir unser recht
um unser recht ukrainisch zu reden
um unser recht keine sklaven der russen
zu sein
das ist ein krieg um unsere existenz und
ich sehe keine diplomatischen lösungen
mehr
der russische präsident habe sich
entschieden so sieht es auch der
historiker timothy snyder die offensive
im osten mache klar dass wladimir putin
die vollständige unterwerfung und die
totale vernichtung des ukrainischen
staates zum ziel habe völkermord nennt
es der amerikanische präsident mit
auswirkungen weit über die ukraine
hinaus es ist wohl nicht übertrieben zu
behaupten dass das schicksal europas als
ein zusammenschluss sicherer demokratien
weitgehend davon abhängt was im nächsten
monat passiert wenn die russen gewinnen
bedeutet das dass alle demokratien mit
gewalt gestürzt und das imperien im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert in europa
erneut florieren können wenn aber die
ukraine gewinnen könnten demokratien
zumindest eine chance
die abfahrt unter der zivilbevölkerung
anton kann nicht verstehen dass
europäische regierungen wie die deutsche
immer noch zögern und nicht sehen was
auch für sie auf dem spiel steht
ich sehe und kenne so viele die mit uns
meinen deutsche aber auf der anderen
seite auf der regierungsseite versteht
man gar nichts
sie verstehen nicht dass sie
verstehen nicht dass wenn der letzte
ukrainische soldat gefallen hast die
europäer dann selber kennen und sie
werden keine chance mehr haben
wegzulaufen
europas zukunft werde sich in der
ukraine entscheiden da sind sich der
pastor und der historiker einig an der
frage ob es europa zulässt dass eine
mächtige diktatur ihre vorstellungen von
geschichte durchsetzt und dafür einen
demokratischen staat und seinen menschen
auslöst